when I read that Donald Trump yesterday
took aim at the American justice system
called it a laughingstock called it a
joke I thought whoa wait a second did
Donald Trump have some Great Awakening
is Donald Trump finally coming out and
calling the American justice system what
it is because it has one version for the
haves and one version for the have-nots
is Trump going to issue a critique of
the war on drugs for deliberately and
disproportionately targeting non-white
Americans is Donald Trump going to call
out the plea deal industrial complex
that has so many potentially not guilty
individuals pleading guilty just to
avoid the potential of incredibly long
jail time is he taking aim at the
structural and justices that pervade the
American justice system and the answer
is no Donald Trump called the US justice
system a joke and a laughingstock
because I guess we haven't been tough
enough and already tortured and found
guilty the New York truck terrorists
from Tuesday's attack
here's Donny boy himself will never ever
forget the beautiful lives that have
been taken from us that was a horrible
event and we have to stop it and we have
to stop it call we also have to come up
with punishment that's far quicker and
far greater than the punishment these
animals are getting right now they'll go
through court for years at the end
they'll be who knows what happens we
need quick justice and we need strong
justice
much quicker and much stronger than we
have right now because what we have
right now is a joke and it's a
laughingstock that is pretty damn clear
right what we have now in terms of the
process of justice is a joke and the
laughingstock and trials take too long
and the punishments aren't strong enough
so there's two issues here one is is
Trump correct but before we get to that
issue 2 is did Trump say it now you
might be saying wait hold David of
course he said it you just played the
video it's very clear
that he said it for some reason Sarah
Huckabee Sanders press secretary hours
later denied that Donald Trump said what
he just said in the video I played for
you the president called the US justice
system a joke and a laughingstock
during his comments he said that the
system of justice in the process has
people calling us a joke and calling us
a laughingstock look I think as I told
Margaret he's simply pointing out his
frustration of how long that this
process takes how costly this process is
and particularly for someone to be
unknown terrorist that that process
shouldn't move faster that's the point
he's making that's the frustration he
had it has not been a particularly good
week for Sarah Huckabee Sanders who do
you believe do you believe the video of
Trump saying it or do you believe Sarah
Huckabee Sanders telling us he didn't
say it straight up lies day after day
so that part is not really the big
headline because we're expecting this
now on a daily basis from Sarah Huckabee
Sanders let's get to the meat of it now
right the long costly process that
doesn't get the right results in our
justice system when it comes to
individuals accused of terror and
horrible violent crimes there are people
who will say we should be trying these
cases like the New York truck driver in
military tribunals up to an including
Gitmo Guantanamo Bay detention center in
Cuba they cite security concerns of
having these really bad dudes in our
regular courts the problem is we've had
no incidents ever that point to the idea
that our court system can't handle
dangerous people we had trials of people
involved with Osama bin Laden and 9/11
there were never any issues our courts
are more than well enough equipped to
handle high-profile accused criminals
that's not a problem whatsoever well
then they'll point to the cost
the truth is it's actually way cheaper
in our regular court system than to
actually carry out a trial at for
example Guantanamo Bay well then they'll
point to the results that we really want
to nail these people we want to crush
them
the truth is that there's a much higher
conviction rate in our regular court
system for these types of crimes then at
Gitmo and then they'll talk about speed
and the truth is that our court system
even though it can sometimes seem kind
of slow it's still carrying out these
trials much faster than we would see it
get Moke cases take forever trials take
forever so fundamentally the argument
from Trump is completely wrong but I'm
kind of making a mistake because I'm
trying to analyze Donald Trump's
comments like he even has any idea what
he's saying he has no idea what he's
talking about he's effectively
criticizing due process which is a core
part of the American justice system and
yes there are major problems with the
American justice system Donald Trump
didn't actually cite any of them but the
last thing that we should be looking to
do is to remove elements of due process
and to get back to the line
I would like to see the press corps that
sits in the press briefing room when
Sarah Huckabee Sanders puts out these
screeds and lies have them make a pact
where they say when we ask a basic
question just on facts and Sarah
Huckabee Sanders tries to deny that
Donald Trump said it let's all make a
pact then agree that we will ask the
same question over and over again as she
calls on each one of us until she
actually answers the question without
denying the premises or more than likely
ends the press briefing early and walks
off stage as we've seen her do when the
questions don't really go the way she
wants them to go I think that that would
be a really interesting thing to see and
I would love it if the press corps would
actually do it will they probably not
send me your thoughts on the constant
line I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show
is on Twitter at David Pakman show we'll
take a break and be back after this
today's episode of the David Pakman show
made possible in part by movement
watches I'm wearing my movement watch
today everywhere I go people like it
people ask me about it they say how much
did that watch cost assuming that it's
somewhere between four and five hundred
dollars and I tell them movement watches
start at just 95 bucks and movement
watches actually started sort of like
the David Pakman show in fact they used
crowdfunding to get off the ground they
have sold over a million watches in more
than
160 countries directly online and that's
how they keep prices low by cutting out
the middleman altogether and you can
save 15% off of a movement watch with
free shipping and free returns by going
to MVM t-dot-com slash pakman save 15%
free shipping free returns
MVM t-dot-com slash Pakman join the
movement